los londinenses se apresuran para hacer
las últimas compras navideñas luego de
que el primer ministro boris johnson
anunciará medidas más severas para la
temporada decembrina todo esto a raíz de
una nueva cepa del corona virus que es
hasta un 70% más transmisible que la
original
dada la evidencia preliminar que tenemos
sobre esta nueva variante del virus y el
riesgo potencial que representa empieza
en el corazón pero debo decirles que no
podemos continuar con la navidad como
estaba planeado en inglaterra quienes
viven en áreas de nivel 4 no deben
mezclarse con nadie fuera de su hogar en
navidad aunque el apoyo continuará para
quienes corren un riesgo particular de
soledad o aislamiento del sur y killer
school lines riseley son las
restricciones para los habitantes del
sureste y este de inglaterra y la ciudad
de londres donde entrarán a nivel 4 es
decir un nivel grave de contagios el
comercio no esencial cierra también los
bares restaurantes museos y queda
prohibido entrar o salir de las zonas
nivel 4
creo que es el movimiento correcto en
este momento con la nueva cepa actual y
entrando en el área puede ser bastante
grave camby cual esters tras el anuncio
de johnson
la ministra principal de escocia
prohibió los viajes a reino unido a
excepción de desplazamientos esenciales
o de urgencia
para reducir el riesgo de que se importe
la cepa de escocia tenemos la intención
de mantener una estricta prohibición de
viajar entre escocia del resto de reino
unido desafortunadamente y lamento mucho
esto
esa prohibición seguiría vigente durante
todo el periodo festivo adquirir la
nueva prohibición en reinounido rige a
partir de este sábado la medianoche el
país suma actualmente más de 2 millones
de contagios y más de 67 mil muertos por
kobe 19